all right joining me now i'm delighted
he's with us newt gingrich former
speaker of the house and fox news
contributor author of defeating big
government socialism
newt
even if biden somehow does declare he's
running for reelection
i isn't it a sure thing that he will be
primaried by a younger
liberal who's considered a better
messenger than he is
oh sure and i also think that you know
if you look at this most recent mansion
monstrosity proposing 87 000
new internal revenue service agents
that's more than we currently have total
so more than double the irs agent these
people don't hear anything and they
don't understand that i think biden is
in trouble but i think the whole
democratic party model is in trouble
because they're so radically out of
touch with the american people and they
can't deliver on daily life on goods and
services
my personal guess is that biden will not
run
and that harris won't run then neither
of them will find
the level of support necessary
to sustain a nationwide campaign in
2023.
now new do you think that they believe
their plans are actually working
because they're they're they're reaching
the point where people are going to use
less travel less
all those things that they love for the
environment or do they think
uh they're working they're not working
really but we still need a new messenger
is it is this all going according to
plan in other words
no look i mean part of the reason i
wrote defeating big government socialism
is that their underlying belief system
for example if you're really hard left
if you're a buddha judge for example
you've never run anything seriously you
bicycle around
he's happy
to have the american people in pain over
paying for gasoline because he thinks
that'll drive them into electric
vehicles which they also currently can't
afford
if you look at the murder rate i mean
the people that george soros has been
electing are happy to release murderers
back on the street and you know i just
saw a new york state senator democratic
senator who said that the men who'd been
put in women's prison because they were
transgender and who had now been caught
raping women shouldn't be prosecuted
because they're women too now i mean if
that's your belief system
and that's the world you live in you
know open borders are fine you just have
a couple million people coming in
although even for the mayors of
washington dc and new york they're going
to be so many illegal immigrants that
they're beginning to complain that it's
literally unmanageable but i think if
you're truly hard left
all of this is acceptable because it's
for this greater mythical belief system
that's almost a religion it's a secular
religion
now newt we just got a fox news alert we
have the new numbers in from that
razorson gop gubernatorial contest in
arizona maricopa county just announced
moments ago
that karen taylor robson is now leading
kerry lake
45.87
to 45.22
that's a difference of 2 650 votes now
the county says it's going to release
updated numbers
tomorrow around 10 p.m that's great for
us because our show starts at 10 pm
eastern
but newt i talked about this with
hannity this is obscene that in the
greatest country in the world we can't
count our votes on election day and
report on election night
what the heck is going on and why is
this still not fixed
well it's it's crazy we just watched a
french national election
and the french national election was
with paper ballots and they were
reported that night
uh there's something profoundly wrong
with the way we approach all this and i
think it'll be interesting tomorrow to
watch because there are other counties
that lake was carrying by pretty good
margins and i don't think they finished
reporting either so
who knows what the final number is going
to be sometime tomorrow and you're right
it is crazy that they can't just get
this done
new thank you great to see you hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else